[Music]
excuse me miss why are you dressed for
laser tag
oh boy you guys don't have any clue do
you I'm here to stop the shapeshifters
that are infiltrating your planet
[Music]
[Music]
connection
Wow Captain Marvel you know you're
glowing right rated pg-13
so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're a tree a race of noble
warriors heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior you were reborn
I keep having these
memories something in my past is the key
to all of this
you know how to fly this thing you'll
see
that's a yes or no question yes
[Music]
would you like to know
what you really are
I think there had a life here
what are you telling me
you've come a long way but you never
strong as you think
this war is just the beginning I'm not
gonna fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
I'm sure the cutest little thing aren't
you
what's your name
[Music]